while the U.S Secretary of State uh
that's Anthony blinken of course he has
urged both Israel and Palestine to
de-escalate violence and restore
security the region is experiencing the
worst violence in years joining us now
is the Israeli ambassador to the United
Kingdom City Valley is that how I
pronounce yes it's nice to see you good
morning joining us how are you going to
de-escalate the violence uh first of all
good morning I'm so happy to be here
with you for the opportunity to speak
about what was going on the weekend in
Israel we had a very difficult weekend
because unfortunately on Friday night
when people were going out of a
synagogue you know Shabbat is the
holiday in our week and they went from
the synagogue to go and have their nice
Friday night dinner they were attacked
by Palestinian terrorists firing with
gun killing seven people
um some of the people I think people
were heartbroken when they the sort of
faces of Usher was a 14 year old young
boy and a nice couple Natalie and Ellie
that just got married two years ago and
they came to help the people that were
injured and unfortunately the terrorist
was so cruel that he was shutting them
um and and that that was the weekend we
went through and when uh when that
happened President Biden called right
away to prime minister Netanyahu he said
this is horrific
um we we are supporting your right for
self-defense and so uh did the foreign
Secretary of the UK James cleverly that
said that on the international day when
we memorized the Holocaust such horrific
sides coming from Jerusalem is something
that nothing can justify you know
harming innocent people so that was a
very very difficult weekend okay
um a father shot dead in front of his
son at a makeshift check point two weeks
ago Israeli soldiers saying he had a
knife later admitted he was unarmed
um there is violence on both sides how
are you going to sort it out
so um it's not violence on both sides it
seems pretty violent so the way we see
it
um Israel is under attack under
terrorism and what we do is in order to
defend ourselves the government is
um committed to defend its people we
don't want people to be shot when they
walk in the streets so This Is Our
obligation so when we do military
actions like we did the defense actions
in Janine last week it's because we had
intelligence alert on another terror
attack That was supposed to come from
Janine Janine became a terror Hub
unfortunately the Palestinian Authority
is at the moment one of its weakness
points where they cannot do anything so
this creates a vacuum and this Terror
hubs need to be controlled and in order
to control that in order to defend
people not to have more terror attacks
in our streets we send our defense
verses in order to make sure that those
kind of Terror attacks won't be a daily
thing your interior minister is a
convicted racist and is Extreme views
towards Palestinians but is now in
charge of police and policing them what
faith should the International Community
have in that
well the Israeli Supreme Court makes the
decision who's racist and is not and it
was very clear when he was running to
office to go into the knesset that the
Israeli Supreme Court says that on the
base of his Manifesto is not under this
definition so first of all I don't agree
with the description but if we go back
policing the Palestinians and he has
extreme views about them but if we go
back to the Israeli government the
Israeli government is a coalition
government is something that in the UK
is not something you have many times I
mean you're used to different type of
systems got to do with his views on on
Palestine I explained because his views
on Palestinian been under review under
judicial review of our Supreme Court and
the Supreme Court said very clearly that
he put one thing in his Manifesto which
is safety in The Straits of Israel and
this is why he was elected so I just
don't agree with the description but if
we go back to the government the
government is being ruled by being
Benjamin netanyahu's party this is the
dominant party and fraud hanging over
him
this is something being checked in a
court and I think his leadership for the
last 20 years was dominanted by a vision
of creating more peace with our
neighbors as you know the Abraham
Accords is something that happened under
his leadership so in the last two years
we had more and more countries joining
to the peace Circle and actually the
visit of Anthony blinken yesterday one
of the main issues in this visit is hard
to extend a peace Circle and how to
bring Saudi Arabia into the circle how
to make sure the region will be more
safe so I really think that this is a
good role model about Israel and Arab
world can create great things together
because the Abraham Accords is being
wonderful success
okay talk to me about why you would
bring
um gun licenses why are you loosening
gun licenses for Israelis how is that
not going to exacerbate the situation so
I'm very happy you're asking about that
because I don't know if people are
familiar with our very very strict gun
laws so Israel has a very strict gun
laws and what the government is doing is
basically allowing just the people that
already have a license people that are
trained are well trained or part of
security and Defense Forces just to
carry their guns in order to you know
prevent this horrific kind of uh you
know terrible and shoot somebody we're
not going to hand out guns I mean just
to make it sure and clear we've got a
gun you're gonna you only have a gun to
shoot somebody no but we have guns in
order to defend ours many people in
Israel as you know we have how do you
defend yourself
no just to explain how the Israeli
system works we have a very strict gun
laws and the people that are allowed to
carry guns are people that are trained
in our security systems because many
people as you know in Israel work on
security work so part of the work of
those security people is if something
horrific like happened Friday night is
happening is to protect the people so
this is part of their Duty or their
civil duty but we are not handing over
guns and the prominences in it very
clearly no one is taking the Law into
his hands we have policing forces and we
have Defense Forces in order to do that
no one is encouraging violence actually
we want to de-escalate so normal
civilians will not be getting guns
absolutely not okay
what is actually happening then when we
you are relaxing the gun laws what does
that actually mean it's not really
relaxing gun laws it's more the people
that are already trained and they're
able that they will be encouraged to
carry those guns in order to protect
people sometimes they take the police
people not to shoot people to protect
people if they're under terror attack
and just to go back to our history so
many times in our history including by
the way the mayor of Jerusalem that was
involved in a middle of a scene of
terrorism so he had to run after a
terrorist when he was firing and
shooting people in the streets of
Jerusalem so unfortunately because
Israel has such a bad experience with
terrorism in our streets sometimes
people that carry guns because they're a
part of security and Defense Forces they
actually saved lives so we're not
speaking in any way on something that is
um you know handing over there has to be
peace otherwise we will continue to see
the death toll rise talk to me about the
importance of taking the houses from the
families of those that are caught up in
terrorism what's the point of that um
first of all let's start with what you
started there must be peace so why there
is no peace if Israel is doing so well
with Egypt with Jordan we have a proven
record of a country that seeks peace in
one's piece so why is it so hard with
our neighbors the Palestinians and I
think some of the answer comes from the
horrible incitement that brings a 13
year old boy to take a gun and as you
said to shot a father and a son one
after the other a 13 year old boy can
you imagine a 13 year old boy anywhere
else in the world taking a gun firing
trying to kill innocent people I think
that's why Insight malicious family's
home again so the reason we're doing it
is in order to discourage the other
people to be involved with terrorism
just not just the child's responsibility
it's the whole family that is
responsible the way we see it the way we
see it it's not the feminist
responsibility or any we see it as look
at what is happening with the
Palestinian Authority delivering
financial support to everyone who's
involved with terrorism there is so much
incentive under the Palestinian
leadership to be involved with terrorism
they actually delivered just to be clear
you're trying to disincentivize other
families by demolishing the homes of
those we make sure that people will
understand that they need to pay a price
for terrorism because at the moment the
only price they're getting is rewards
from the Palestinians is it the whole
family's responsibility but we're saying
again this is not a punishment for the
for the for the Family itself
because you need to take responsibility
for the fact that your Palestinian
authorities actually giving you this
motivation to go and kill instant Jews
in the streets I mean this is a pure
anti-Semitism think about it if someone
would have taken a gun here in London
would have shut juice just because there
are Jews the whole country would have
been in headlines saying this is
horrific this is anti-Semitism in Israel
in in some very strange way people are
saying no well you need to understand
the circumstances nothing can justify
hurting innocent people and this is
what's happening on both sides I suppose
but again we don't need innocent people
well does it as I just pointed out to
you we don't Target innocent people um
at a checkpoint and he was unarmed in
front of his child
that actually it's not correct because
we never Target innocent people never
Israel is doing everything in order to
Target terrorists and this is what we
need to do in order to make sure that
our streets will be peaceful what would
be a good result uh when Anthony blinker
gets back on the plane to go back to
America so there are three issues that
he came to discuss first is Palestinian
terrorism and I think part of it is
again to make sure the leadership of the
Palestinians will be taken into account
for those horrible incitements and the
fact they're celebrating when Jews being
killed 30 seconds to the second issue is
Iran I think this is the most important
on extending the circle of Peace so I
think all together I think it will be
very successful will extend circle of
peace and will continue to do the great
work we do on Iran we just had the
biggest exercise between Israeli defend
forces and American defend forces last
week out of time thank you your
Excellency for joining us I really
appreciate hopeful peaceful days yeah
absolutely thank you it's good to see
you thank you for joining us on the
program